[Music]
and so the question comes up when did we
invent clothes and who did and I can you
know judging by the record I can say
that only humans were the only ones who
ever wore clothes woolly mammoths didn't
wear clothes the rule is never wear
clothes they were in in Africa you know
and so the question is what objective
evidence do we have of clothes right
Moto's never any clothes found no no
clothes found but we find other other
things that indicate whether there could
be enclosed one of them is the needle
you need needles to sew hides together
so when they find the needle is the
other why would they invent the needle
right and the first needle that we have
today you see it here in Delson mm and
cyclopædia of human evolutionary history
mean the oldest needle found yeah and
they say buona notte no needles first
appeared the solutrean period 22,000 to
17,000 years ago of the upper
Palaeolithic and suggest the sewing of
hides with a thread made of sinew and
vegetable material so that's the first
needle we found or the ones that you
know I'm sorry you know but at least
again we're talking about objective data
and you know we don't see the same thing
for a nano though you don't find a
Neanderthal needle like they could have
they could have taken a bone from some
kind of animal even if it was a crude
needle you know and they could have some
some kind of string and tie their
heights together we have no evidence of
string or needles maybe they're tools
maybe they did but they didn't need it
for what they did you know these these
these hominids it all the head is these
axes yes and they are having big tools
course one big stones and they just
killed animal didn't need to have
sophisticated things like oh I'm gonna
so today
well what tools did they find of the
Neanderthals again all these they
attributed to they find these big
hatchets these clunky Spears these these
are all working and hunting and stone
yeah wood and stone but again you know
sometimes they say that things like
string which could be made out of plants
that would survive over time so needles
maybe yeah so this is this is what they
say now they didn't find there there's a
there's a claim is in the Siberian Times
Russian magazine says world's oldest
needle Fung in Siberian cave that
stitches together human history a few
thousand sixteen fine
yeah but the issue is that these people
make this claim as always you know the
everybody likes to make outrageous
claims without any real objective
evidence he said they found it in this
cave out there in Siberia but then we
have a statement by write this group
right 2010 it says we and this is
interesting said we did it seven bone
fragments found close to the hominin
ramie remains in layer eleven in the
east and south galleries of the same
cave right four of the seven dates are
infinite dates older than fifty thousand
years before the present whereas three
are finite dates between sixteen
thousand and thirty thousand years
before the president what does this mean
this layer
eleven eleven was contaminated by by two
different timeframes one was what was
yes like a hotel different people do
over thousands of years in this cave and
they and in later eleven where they
excavate say well here we find bones
from fifty thousand years ago or
artifacts or whatever and here we find
that the same layer we find you know
things from sixty thousand years ago so
we don't know is this needle that these
people claimed they found dates the
fifty thousand years ago or sixteen
thousand years ago could it be made by
you know Neolithic people for all we
know yeah yeah which is less than ten
thousand years ago so so you know these
are outrageous claim
that these people made another another
source for clothes is lice they came up
with a theory that says that we lost our
body lice that we yeah yeah because
supposedly
we lost our body hair and the theory
that of why we lost their body here is
that we there was like a tendency to get
rid of lice so this is the theory in
retrospect they say that we lost their
body here so the lice in our body would
not have a place to hide
okay so there's like food from the pen
here yeah yeah yeah well why aren't we
all bald
yeah well again and they get gorillas
and chimps they have lice you see them
grooming each other said they live in
the equator close to the equator so they
didn't lose their hair because it was
too hot they didn't lose their hair
because of lice but the theory is that
we lost our body here too so that
thought elisha wouldn't have a place to
hide right so we had body lice over time
we lost our hair and now that we got
really fine you got rid of the lice
leading in the ones in the ones in our
these are humans in Africa right but
then there's several problems with that
theory and again they say they give a
timeframe here but maybe seventy-five
thousand one hundred seventy-five
thousand years ago
that's what body lights eat bald from
hair lice so we used to have hair lice
and approximately maybe they do this
from genetic and houses regression
analysis they say you know from our
calculations body lice began to exist
you know they evolved from from
headlights approximately or at most one
hundred seventy five thousand years
that's kind of hard to make sense of
because why would the body lice emerge
when we start losing our body here or
when we start having the tendencies to
lose our body here yeah sometimes
crisscross there again and and I have a
lot of questions about that few Eve from
different angles one is that you know
here we lose our body
here and the body lights are now gone
because now finally got rid of that pest
now you go out there hunt an animal take
its hideout and put it on top of us and
we bring the lights back on this so it's
like you know we defeat the purpose so
I'm not sure that body lice has anything
to do with why we lost hair I mean we
tossed here and that's it
why are we talking about hair loss
because we're assuming that humans were
completely bald except like you say the
head and we migrated now to Europe and
now you notice that it's cold but we
don't have the adaptation tube you know
that snow into the cold weathers well so
now now we start putting clothes off we
also don't have that fat that's right
right and so we have to use now we have
this so you know stitch hides together
with needles and say oh you know we have
a need now we have a need for clothes
because we don't have that natural
resistance that the animal had so why we
lost our hair is still in the air we
still don't know that for sure
but we could extrapolate that we made
clothes because we didn't have hair when
we went to the north right right and
then there's a third one so we have you
know we have the needle we have a lice
now there is the scrapers they found
scrapers for the old age including for
and results where they say these
scrapers were used to pull the hide from
the meat okay and so they say I see here
we have evidence that see they pull this
the skin off and they put it on five
persons they didn't want hair you mean
and I think that's that's the reason
they built these they may be swingers
it's the pull so they didn't want to eat
you know this this hide so they pulled
it off and they use them you know they
eat the meat that's one the elements it
could have make tents for all we know
there may be you know carpets we don't
know what they use the the high toilet
is throwing or maybe they throw them
away you know maybe they stank so much
you know brought a little all the fleas
is or flies they say no
you know I don't want that stinky thing
near me it smells too much it is all
these flies forget it
so you know that's no telling what the
shapers were used yeah we don't we don't
know why these are these are fears or
interesting theories but we should not
put our hand in the fire for them you
know you can't say Oh scrapers are proof
that we built that they built closed
lights are proof that you know we lost
our hair and later on we need it clothes
to fill the hole you know that we left
behind and needles yeah there are
evidence that we use them for something
obviously if you have needles and
especially if you have some kind of
string out there it was almost certainly
used for sewing but we don't have that
evidence for an animal so so we don't
have any evidence whatsoever that
Neanderthals use clothes what we do have
is a reasoning process where we say whoa
how did Homo erectus survive there you
know in the old days there in the cold
yeah and then called then that's where
they grew up so they almost vibart from
birth they had to have that resistance
to cold they had they must have had that
extra big fat under their skin and extra
air Neanderthals I mean and even before
then yeah my right has had to live in
the Arctic already and in essence and
there you see how interesting it is
they always dress and their thoughts
with clothes but they never addressed
Homo erectus or heidelbergensis with
clothes they only dress Neanderthals
with clothes because that you know
because of the mating they never suggest
even that we slept with Michael Birds
so the erectus in Europe was hairy the
heidelburgh was hairy and then we have
this Neanderthal it was hairy but all of
a sudden he needs clothes yeah yeah and
so the question is the end results have
clothes in fact all these director movie
directors from documentaries they always
dress the Neanderthals up in clothes I
mean why don't they dress the woolly
mammoth it in snow shoes while you're at
it you know or whatever it doesn't make
any sense
there is no justification for to dress
Neanderthals with clothes they did not
have though this is a gorilla or an
Arctic
now there's another issue and that's you
know there is the issue that the reason
the animals had closed is they could
survive the cold that's a sin see what
people have in their mind is well how
could how could an animal live in such
low tempered by a lock on snow barefoot
but wolves can will sleep in the snow
so do polar bears now take this polar
bear to him to the equator see if he
survives so it is same thing with the
end of the mammoth is this thick layer
of fat you know and probably very hairy
gorilla and and he's used to the cold
he's not going to put anything on
because it doesn't need it first of all
there's no justification for him to
evolve clothes and then I cannot imagine
the end of them going farther south like
to equator and saying oh this is sunny
this is warmer weather thank God no he
was an Arctic animal that's what he was
and he lived there and he died there you
know he never came out of there so again
you know wolves they don't need clothes
woolly mammoths don't need clothes will
be rhinos that used to live in those
they possibly the woolly hippo
there was a hippo you know there was a
hippo in Europe also a normal hippo but
he was like northern hippo he died out
also I think like 25,000 years ago and
this hippo probably was woolly - we
don't know because you know you don't
have skin from this animal but my point
here is that I think that Neanderthal
was the woolly man he was a woolly man
is the Eddy the end of those live in all
of Europe like all the way down to
southern Europe and they lived all the
way to Italy yeah southern part of Italy
in Greece and Yugoslavia but but keep in
mind that the glaciers were all the way
to the Alps so it was cold weather all
the way that was in the Mediterranean
Mediterranean wasn't frozen
no it wasn't frozen you west from the
Mediterranean wasn't frozen but for Homo
erectus to make it to England the
channel yeah that today is
strip of water was frozen they come
across into England you know on foot
I'm saying it's another reason is
another cold it's another reason
explaining how or why the Neanderthals
didn't go to the South because they had
the Mediterranean in the way well they
could have gone through through Turkey
and that's this round and again they
would have to cross the you know the
what is there the little strip of water
that's between Turkey and the mainland
European mainland something not sure
they even took the trouble why I don't
know not only that but they have
probably enough game in their own region
they have no reason to go to Israel or
to the Middle East so the question is
whether the Middle Eastern so-called
nano-cells were really Anders or some
kind of archaic human and there are
these two opinions today but for sure
the ones in the Middle East did not
match the Neanderthals in Western Europe
they're they're noticeably different
they're measurably different okay you
can see the zooming assuming yeah but I
mean that's the point if they are nano
though they're different but more than
likely they're just our takings
[Music]
Oh God tell what does it take to put
some sense into the minds of those
people who think that their
great-grandmother's descent from the man
themself
well let me tell you what I think
[Music]